Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonsoir.
On va se plonger ensemble
dans le Paris de la fin du 19ᵉ siècle.
Plus précisément le 9 octobre 1890,
dans le parc du château de
Gretz-Armainvilliers, en Seine-et-Marne.
L’ingénieur français, Clément Ader, est
assis aux commandes de son invention :
l’Éole.
Il s’agit là de l’un des premiers
prototypes d’avion au monde.
Ce sont des aboutissements de recherche
et de développement pour l’ingénieur.
C’est surtout l’occasion pour lui
de réaliser son rêve d’enfance,
prendre son envol.
Il active les commandes de son engin,
qu’il a doté d’un moteur de 20 chevaux
et d’une impressionnante armature
en bois, en soie, en bambou,
d’un peu plus de 14 mètres d’envergure.
Il active les commandes.
Et l’Éole commence à s’élancer
sur la piste aménagée
de plus de 200 mètres de long.
Clément Ader ressent les soubresauts
des roues en contact avec la piste.
Et puis, plus rien.
Sous le regard émerveillé de ses proches,
l’Éole va s’élever
de quelques dizaines de centimètres
et va surtout réaliser un bond
d’une cinquantaine de mètres de long.
Est-ce qu’il s’agissait là
du premier vol motorisé de l’histoire,
plus de dix ans avant celui
des frères Wright ?
Est-ce que Clément Ader a inventé
ce jour-là l’aviation moderne ?
En fait, malheureusement pour lui,
il n’a jamais réussi
à le prouver officiellement
parce que les seuls témoins présents
sur place, c’était ses proches.
Sauf que, sans vraiment le savoir,
Clément Ader s’est démarqué par
un autre fait qui est tout aussi insolite.
Parce que l’Éole, ça ressemble à ça.
Pour imaginer et concevoir son engin,
il a confié s’être inspiré du vol
de chauve-souris d’un peu plus
d’un mètre d’envergure,
appelées les roussettes des Indes.
Il les a observées planer,
dans son jardin privé, dans sa volière.
Quand on regarde l’Éole,
on y reconnaît facilement
la morphologie de la chauve-souris.
Regardez les ailes.
Les membranes en soie reproduisent
la voilure de l’animal,
tandis qu’en fait l’armature imite
presque trait pour trait le squelette,
les tendons et les muscles
de la chauve-souris.
Ainsi, s’il n’a jamais réussi
à formellement démontrer
qu’il était un pionnier de l’aviation,
il n’en demeure pas moins vrai que
Clément Ader s’est inscrit dans l’Histoire
pour un autre fait notable.
Car en fait, avec l’Éole,
il est devenu l’un des pionniers
de ce qu’on appelle le biomimétisme.
Le biomimétisme, c'est s'inspirer
de la nature pour innover.
C’est cette discipline tout à fait
particulière et étonnante,
qui consiste à imiter
l’ingéniosité du vivant
pour refaçonner,
réinventer nos technologies.
J’ai découvert le biomimétisme
il y a cinq ans exactement,
[précisément] au travers de l’histoire
que je viens de vous raconter.
Je me suis pris de passion
pour ce domaine.
J'en ai même fait mon métier.
Et le biomimétisme,
si je suis là ce soir devant vous,
c’est parce que je suis convaincu
que c’est une des meilleures options
pour réinventer notre futur.
Pour comprendre le biomimétisme,
il faut comprendre son origine.
Il faut comprendre ce miracle
des probabilités apparu sur Terre,
il y a des milliards d’années : la vie.
La vie fut d’abord dominée
par des organismes unicellulaires,
puis elle s’est peu à peu complexifiée
dans cette danse perpétuelle
qu’on appelle l’évolution.
Et le résultat de cette formidable
épopée du vivant,
ce qu’on appelle la biodiversité,
c’est une richesse infinie.
C'est plus de 1,7 million
d'espèces différentes.
On en découvre
15 000 de plus chaque année.
De l’éléphant à la baleine,
aux champignons, aux bactéries,
en passant par l’espadon, l’acacia,
le crocodile, le papillon,
la tulipe ou encore le crabe,
tous ces êtres vivants sont
au sommet de l’évolution.
Et plus on prend le temps de les observer,
plus on se rend compte de
leur incroyable sophistication.
Tous ont parfaitement su s’adapter
aux contraintes de leur environnement
et à leurs besoins physiologiques.
Au travers des millénaires,
ils ont été dotés, ou ils ont développé,
un ensemble, un vivier de mécanismes,
de fonctions, de propriétés,
de matériaux et même de
comportements cognitifs,
allant même jusqu’à coder l’information
avant même qu’on crée
le premier ordinateur.
La nature, c’est bien simple,
en fait, elle sait tout faire.
Elle sait créer et gérer de l’information.
Elle sait stocker de l’énergie.
Elle sait fabriquer, elle sait inventer,
elle sait transformer des matériaux
multifonctionnels et sobres.
Elle sait filtrer.
Elle sait purifier.
La nature sait même gérer des procédés
chimiques ultra complexes
et en même temps profondément sobres.
En fait, c’est bien simple,
la nature, ce n’est pas un gisement
de fonctions élémentaires ou frugales.
À l’inverse, c’est un gisement de leçons
et de fonctions, de stratégies,
de techniques ultra éprouvées
et en même temps profondément soutenables.
Et l’homme, lui, il est apparu en bas de
la toute dernière page du livre de la vie.
Et vous le savez aussi bien que moi,
au travers des révolutions
industrielles successives,
nous avons réussi à perturber
ces fragiles écosystèmes.
Nous avons réussi à hypothéquer
non seulement notre propre avenir,
mais aussi celui des millions
d’autres espèces.
L’humanité, en fait, elle est désorientée,
elle se recherche un futur.
De toute évidence, elle est
à la recherche de solutions
qui permettraient de changer la donne,
de transformer notre paradigme
économique et industriel.
Alors, on fait quoi ?
Eh bien justement, le biomimétisme,
il s’est construit au travers
de ces biologistes, ces ingénieurs,
ces chercheurs, ces entrepreneurs
qui ont compris
que, face aux défis de notre temps,
la nature nous offrait la plus élégante
et la plus évidente des solutions :
3,8 milliards d'années de recherche
et de développement.
En découvrant l’univers du biomimétisme,
à titre personnel, il y a deux histoires
qui m’ont profondément marqué.
La première, c’est celle d’une équipe de
chercheurs belges, canadiens et français
qui sont allés regarder
du côté des lucioles.
Les lucioles, vous le savez,
ce sont ces insectes qui communiquent
grâce à la lumière naturelle
qu'ils fabriquent par réaction chimique
au sein même de leur abdomen.
Le problème,
c’est que pour passer de l’abdomen
à l’extérieur du corps de l’insecte,
la lumière doit traverser sa carapace,
ce qu’on appelle la cuticule.
Au niveau de la cuticule, la déperdition
de la lumière doit être minimale
pour éviter toute surconsommation
énergétique de la part de la luciole.
Justement, pour optimiser
la transmission de la lumière,
la magie de l’évolution a doté
la luciole d’une carapace
à la structure ultrasophistiquée.
Voici ce que les biologistes
ont découvert :
une multitude de petites écailles
chevauchantes
et disposées en toits d’usine.
Ces petites écailles,
elles font dix microns de large.
C’est un dix millionième de mètre.
Elles vont améliorer la transmission
de la lumière.
Elles vont éviter aux rayons
de se réfléchir vers l’intérieur
quand ils veulent traverser la carapace.
Et ça, ça a permis d'améliorer des LED.
Les chercheurs ont eu
l’idée simple mais brillante
de reproduire cette structuration
ultra particulière,
cette anatomie de la carapace
de la luciole,
sur la coque, sur la surface
externe des LED.
Ces dispositifs,
il y en a plein dans la salle,
se démocratisent un peu partout
dans le monde.
Ce qu’ils ont fait, c’est simple,
sur quelques microns, ils ont taillé
ces motifs d’écailles en toits d’usine.
Et le résultat est bluffant :
à consommation énergétique égale,
ils ont réussi à augmenter l’intensité
de la LED de plus de deux tiers.
C'est autant d'économie d'énergie.
Voilà comment le biomimétisme
au travers de bioluminescence
peut aider à refaçonner
l’éclairage moderne.
La deuxième histoire est
tout aussi fascinante.
Vous le savez aussi bien que moi,
on l’a vécu la semaine dernière,
les canicules vont être de plus en plus
fréquentes et intenses.
C’est surtout le cas dans les villes
et centres urbains ultra minéralisés.
La question qui se pose,
c’est comment fait-on pour protéger
nos bâtiments du rayonnement du soleil ?
Eh bien, une équipe de chercheurs
américains et suisses
sont allés regarder du côté
des fourmis argentées.
Elles vivent dans le désert du Sahara.
En journée, la température
peut atteindre plus de 70 °C.
Sauf que pour la fourmi,
c’est une balade de santé,
elle est capable de survivre
à ces chaleurs extrêmes.
Ce que les biologistes ont compris,
c’est que pour se protéger
du rayonnement de la lumière,
du rayonnement du soleil,
la fourmi est dotée de poils
ultrasophistiqués,
à la forme très particulière.
Leur coupe est triangulaire et ondulée.
Et  ça permet un effet de prisme optique
qui va refléter plus de 70%
de la lumière incidente,
et surtout les infra-rouges.
Leur idée a été très simple, c'est de
reproduire cette morphologie particulière
sur des revêtements en polymère
pour toiture de bâtiments.
Le résultat est assez phénoménal.
On obtient un bâtiment capable de refléter
une grande majorité de la lumière
et de refroidir passivement le bâtiment,
de le protéger contre
les rayons du soleil.
Cette idée biomimétique,
cette technologie bio-inspirée,
elle est prodigieuse
et promise à un bel avenir.
La réalité, c’est que des exemples
comme ça, il y en a des milliers d’autres,
que j’ai découverts, qu’on a référencés
avec mon équipe
ou qu’on développe nous-mêmes.
J’aurais très bien pu vous parler
de nouveaux matériaux cosmétiques
écologiques qui sont inspirés
des exosquelettes de scorpion.
J’aurais pu vous parler de comment
la salive des termites nous inspire
pour concevoir des nouveaux liants
de matériaux de construction écologiques.
J’aurais pu vous dire comment
les yeux des écrevisses
ont inspiré des nouveaux chauffages
à haut rendement
qui permettent de réduire
la consommation énergétique
de géants entrepôts aux États-Unis.
Ou j’aurais pu vous dire comment
les essaims de criquets,
qui ont des tactiques
d’évitement anti-collision,
permettent d’inspirer des nouvelles
générations d’algorithmes
pour les véhicules autonomes.
La réalité, c’est que le biomimétisme,
il nous concerne tous.
Le biomimétisme,
il offre des solutions robustes
et des solutions intelligentes
pour l’ensemble des acteurs
technologiques industriels,
quel que soit le domaine.
Et finalement,
on le voit au travers de l’explosion
du nombre de publications scientifiques
et du nombre de brevets,
qui atteste d’une chose,
c’est que le biomimétisme,
il est en plein essor
à l’échelle internationale.
Mais le biomimétisme doit surtout être vu
pour sa promesse fondamentale.
Il peut nous aider à redessiner,
à réinventer notre futur.
C’est une triste chose de songer
que la nature parle,
mais que le genre humain n’écoute pas.
Désormais, je considère
que c’est une invitation.
L’être humain, au travers de ses
révolutions industrielles successives,
au travers de l’artificialisation
progressive de ses sociétés,
s’est peu à peu cru détaché de la nature.
Un peu par péché d'orgueil, on s'est cru
aussi affranchi du reste du vivant.
Ayons l’humilité de
nous reconnecter à la nature.
Prenons le temps, le recul
et ayons la lucidité
d’observer la magie de ses enseignements.
C'est une question de cohérence.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)